[Music]
oh no impostor again
every time and we are a crewmate
oh gosh man i'm already nervous i've
gone for the minion look today
look at me swagging homie no sabotaging
oh lights are off the kill's about to
happen staying alive
the timing of that is impeccable dude i
should stack you
no i'm not going to turn that jimmy i'm
putting my trust in you
you never really know you can't
where was it somebody who went to lights
has killed the big joshua on the way out
on the way out i'm still in i was
literally with everyone
vic what were you doing leaving lights i
ran past jimmy going away from lights
when they were off
well jimmy's been bad quiet so i was
literally with the group of five people
the entire time
yeah but you didn't go to light straight
away and why was that
yo i never i'm gonna save it for later
all right here i'll break it up i paid a
private investigator to watch all your
videos
and take notes of how you guys act when
you're imposter so i would know oh wow
you are joking let me read the notes for
vic vic
is one of the more experienced players
and he definitely takes charge when he's
a poster
oh oh that's enough for me say
say that's enough for me no chance
there you go get out of here i got notes
on all of you
that's the best the slobby's ever had oh
my god
i can't believe that i think he's jimmy
i don't know
i can't believe that worked he knows
he's got private investigators to watch
us
that is amazing i gotta stay with some
of the uk people because they believe
each other
more because they're friends all right
get out of here
get these tests done cause i'm a task
candy
no all right well no one's sabotaging so
that might have actually been vic
there's no way to see where's the
cameras how can you see cameras
all right we're just we're just
slaughtering people
why oh my gosh so many people are dead i
can't go that way there's
that person up there
all right the body's in electrical oh my
god bro
what's what's happened it was definitely
not vic
what the heck oh my god so many people
are gone
oh yeah why are you so shocked man i
just saw you vent
what no i made that up i just wanted to
see if you would fold
all right well i know i know i'm a crew
mate i have a question so harold
you're road to shot right i am yes
harold
okay well i think it's jimmy what what
did i do
because you voted out vickstar who's an
innocent and also
whenever lights went off you didn't go
straight to electrical hold on hold on
carl carl
hold on we have to shoot here we have to
shoot here go on call ksi what task were
you doing
i saw charlo just chilling in the
center place i'm voting jimmy well now
i'm voting carl i'm getting sass of him
all right
no chandler oh hey
we won that's fun we okay
there we go no carl had it as well
nobody listens to carl
ah again a y
i'm not actually imposter this time so
now my notes are actually relevant
i feel violated i feel like he knows
more about me than i know about myself
now
and i don't like that oh
oh oh i get so nervous doing this
in this lobby you always gotta go you
gotta test these ones
oh damn
i knew jj was coming from a sus place
bro
okay who did it i found the body on my
way to electrical
and harold why do you call him harold
why do you say it like that harold
i'm also stupid let's take that into
account so it where was it you said
electrical it was on the way to
electrical so it's between nab and
electrical
we can actually vouch everyone here by
the way jimmy harold
joshua me toby were all on the
right-hand side yeah i was on the
left-hand side
going to reactor me and carl are clear i
was with chandler in medbay and then i
walked away from him there is a world
where he vented
why wouldn't i kill you we were the only
ones in there i'm saying there's a world
where he vented from medbay
carl no you're if you're doing that
right now you might be the other
imposter
we're running out of time everyone skip
if we weren't all stupid we could have
figured it out
i'm obsessed with you for saying that
carl if i thought it's jj
oh wow is that you yeah why would
carl do that chandler gets so defensive
i wasn't saying anything
i'm gonna go into reactor and i think
i'm gonna die here
download while we're here
[Music]
oh it needs to get killed when the
lights go can you still do other tests
or do the does that yes you can
but you shouldn't i just watched vic
walk up to a thing stand at it for like
20 seconds i did the leaves the toss
board didn't do this again you got to do
this again
jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy the
taskbar doesn't move right now the
taskbar doesn't move during beta all
right skip vote i suck just skip it
everyone skip it i am embarrassed skip
it hey keep in mind
let's put sus on me chandler vickstar
and ksi because if you guys are all
actually vouching then one of us is a
killer
all right carl you're acting man what's
your notes on ksi
psi defensive as imposter and can fumble
with this story
doesn't work well under pressure
he also laughs like a psychopath all
right let's put the pressure on him
yo hey yo why
why defensive see that oh
wait all right well oh we got that out
of the way
let's smashed an asteroid though
[Music]
i give up nope that's my weakness i'm
not even not even trying that one
i've just run past car that's really
[Music]
who's dead oh you've lost harold you've
lost harold
oh and simon okay just throwing
information out into the universe
i'm in the top right i see harry as i'm
doing my asteroids and weapons i come
down to nav
i see carl yeah and in between that is a
dead body well i assume they found the
other body
i'm the person that just found a body in
o2 well i feel like
vic star is taking charge right now yeah
true and it was that the case last time
vickstar yes you just walked past the
body
did i i don't i did well i didn't so
oh it's fumbling on the pressure oh
fumbling you're stealing ksi's
notes vote for changing okay i'm
suspicious of a self report all right
i mean laurel is very success i'm very
successful how am i being sus
because earlier i wouldn't have killed
and self-reported right in front of
vickstar
who who else went right who else went
right i don't think it was vic because i
saw vic
doing o2 with harry we don't shoot here
because it's seven
don't then we shoot on seven quite often
no you don't shoot on seven
thug life you shoot on seven if you're
sure but if you're oh [ __ ] we should we
shoot we shoot
whoa who are we going i'm supposed to be
the american why are you guys shooting
with a sidemen with shooters
call the button and shoot again call the
button and shoot again goodbye carl
jimmy jimmy stay with me chandler we got
to stay together they hate their america
oh right oh no i got the electric i'm
going to die an electric
worst place to be oh nobody's pressing
the button
[Music]
told ya from the get-go i told
[Music]
vic this doesn't look good describe it
describe what you saw jj
i saw you just kill where in lights
lights were after yeah you're chatting i
think this is
why the lights are nice how is it
self-report when you did it vic
let me put this out there there's five
people left so if we pick wrong the
imposters win
if you want to bring up some more notes
feel free but yeah yeah
well i mean i feel like vicky is taking
charge vic i wouldn't normally bet him
the only reason i'm suss is because you
came up before
the detective did say vic is more
confident and better at
handling faking being imposter he did
say that please vote for jj
we gotta pick someone we don't we don't
jj is the last imposter i'm i'm fairly
sure
i'm gonna skip i'm confident in that why
would you skip why would you skip
why would you skip vic you're moving sus
though you're moving sauce
shut up i won't hear it from you i say
we follow jj
jimmy stay with me why would you skip if
case i said he saw vic starkill
that means it has to be one of the two
jj just say to vic well you're about to
die then in it
[Music]
so it's done it's toby and jj in it
could it be toby
but he did vouch for me before which he
just wouldn't do he would let me get
voted off
i don't like the way jj said you're
about to die then was that him
insinuating he's about to kill him
i'm gonna call another meeting i really
don't like the way that sounded three
two one bye
you guys are terrible all of you are so
bad
[Laughter]
i said it from the get-go ksi said he
saw fixed our kill
well thank you everybody for watching
subscribe to sidemen
and we'll see you in whatever they're
doing next